(relaxing music)
- [Narrator] At Fairmont
Hotels around the world
there is an elite fellowship
that was founded 17 years ago,
right here in Canada.
The fellowship of canine ambassadors.
I've been a canine ambassador
at the Fairmont Chateau
Lake Louise for eight years now.
What a life this is, let me tell ya.
My name is Marcus, and
I'm the resident good boy
at the Fairmont Chateau Lake Louise.
This here is a magical place.
Banff National Park in Alberta, Canada.
Home to almost 10,000 foot mountain peaks,
meadows covered in wildflowers,
and glacier lakes that are
the richest shade of blue.
That's Bear, he's the new pup
over at the Fairmont Banff Springs.
He's a bit more high-energy than me.
We canine ambassadors
live with a member of the
Fairmont team and what we
do at our hotels is simple:
make people feel at home when
they're away from theirs.
As the wise old dog that I am,
I've learned a lot about the world.
I've made sure that Bear knows
all the secrets to happiness here.
I've let him know about giving kisses,
greeting visitors at the front door,
accompanying visitors on hikes,
and I've also let him
know about the one kind
of extra special visitor: these guys.
If you wanna know about how we feel about
being canine ambassadors, here's an idea:
come by and see for yourself.
It's a good life!
(light music)